did you think the latest MCU film was
all about the wakandans and telecons
tucked into the corner of the movie
screen where some Easter eggs you may
have missed which hint out what a
certain pint-sized hero may be up to
Black Panther wakanda forever closes out
phase for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with perhaps the Studio's most emotional
outing the film follows the great people
of wakanda after the tragic death of
t'challa wakanda forever begins with
shuri racing against the clock to save
her brother from an unspecified illness
despite her efforts t'challa dies and
leaves this world to be with his
ancestors much of the movie is then set
a year after t'challa's death showing
shuri's continued study of technology
and science while she struggles with her
grief while the film's overall storyline
pays tribute to Bozeman and his MCU
Legacy the plot does work to intertwine
black panther wakanda forever with the
mcu's overarching story plan Marvel is
known for intricately weaving its films
together and there's one very important
Easter egg that fans are spotting and
it's all in preparation for the mcu's
next highly anticipated release Snippets
of CNN newscasts are sprinkled
throughout the film the clip show
Anderson Cooper giving news that helps
to propel the story forward and
sharp-eyed viewers are noticing a nod to
another Marvel Superhero while Cooper
reports the news of the day in the
Marvel Studios subreddit one redditor
wrote did anyone catch Scott Lang as
writing a memoir on the CNN news scroll
I got a good chuckle out of that a
fellow Reddit user replied look out for
the little guy this seems to be the
title for Scott's upcoming Memoir Scott
Lang is known to the world as a
superhero Ant-Man and first appeared in
his 2015 solo flick Lang is an ex-con
who's recruited to break into a house
hours after he's released from jail
during the break-in Scott finds the
Ant-Man suit created by scientist Dr
Hank Pym the suit allows Scott to
communicate with ants and make dramatic
changes to his height and Scott's book
detailing his journey from ex-con to
superhero isn't the only big news that
fans are noticing on the bottom of the
big screen One redditor Believes they
saw mention him on autobiography tour
while another posted about Scott's
potential podcast of course references
to Scots are all in anticipation for
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania this
will be the third movie centered around
man and it's the initial installment in
Phase 5 in the MCU the first trailer
released just a few weeks before the
premier black panther wakanda forever
shows Scott Baskin and his superhero
Fame and enjoying life after coming back
from the blip but he is called back into
action when his daughter Cassie creates
a satellite that sends a signal into the
quantum realm Janet Van Dyne who spent
decades trapped inside the quantum realm
warns Cassie of sending such a signal
but it appears her warning is not heated
as the trailer shows Scott Cassie and
the pims digging deeper into the quantum
realm they will also face King the
Conqueror and it's a Face-Off that
director Peyton Reed is looking forward
to Reed recently told Entertainment
Weekly I grew up reading the comics and
I knew the character of Kang the
Conqueror who's one of the big big bad
characters in the comics so to be able
to put up our heroes against King the
Conqueror was a huge thing for us
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
flies onto the big screen on February 17
2023.